if you are an interesting large amount
of data for analysis or looking to
simplify the development of event-driven
micro-services then you need to check
out cloud pub/sub pops up made easy is a
series dedicated to helping you
understand cloud pops up inside out so
let's get started by going through an
overview today
[Music]
Adam and I are collaborating on a
project but we are based in different
parts of the wood I'm here in California
and he is in Australia so I just do my
part on the Google Doc and assign it to
him for review and he does the same this
allows us to receive messages and act on
them in our own working hours
essentially asynchronously we don't have
to be available at the same time and are
still able to get the project done that
pops up is based on the same concept but
for applications and services pops up
helps build robust scalable systems of
applications by integrating them
asynchronously yeah out is a website to
purchase fun cat posters when a user
orders a pretty poster cat out packages
the order ships it to the user and
notifies them in a very simplistic
service-oriented architecture they would
need at least four micro services a
packaging service to pack the poster a
shipping service you know to generate
labels and a notification service to
send notification to the user about the
status of their order all these tied to
an order manager service credit that
there'll be some payment services or
reporting service etc but for the
purpose of this conversation let's
assume those all exist now let's trace
what happens when a user orders a piece
of art the order service receives the
order and sends a message to the
packaging service the packaging service
then does the necessary processing to
package the poster and sends a message
to the shipping service to ship it
the shipping service does the necessary
processing to ship the package and sends
a message to the notification service
which notifies the customer that an
order is processed in the same way the
order and packaging service also send
messages to the notification service to
send to the customer the updated
information on their order there are
some problems with this arrangement
though one it's just complicated with a
lot of arrows but as we drill deeper
what happens if a service say the
packaging service fields well we need
some kind of retry mechanism that will
keep the whole system from baking hmm
can be done but
what happens if a new service gets
introduced like a monitoring service
that logs all of these transactions to a
central store this service needs to
interface with all the other services
which will also require making a change
in all the other services that makes the
developers work really hard think about
testing that would be hard - we will
need mock services to test each of the
individual service let's say I need to
test my packaging service because it is
dependent on the shipping order and
notification service I need to mock up
all of those services just to test my
packaging service which is a lot of work
what if you want to scale this system if
there are three instances of packaging
service there would be a load balancer
involved you would not know how to
cancel the order which stage it is in
and can it still be canceled this is
where cloud pops up comes to rescue
cloud pub/sub is a fully managed
real-time messaging service that allows
you to send and receive messages between
independent applications once an event
is successfully published as a message
it becomes the job of this service to
ensure that all the systems that need to
react to this event get it the idea
behind a synchronous integrations is to
react to events represented as messages
in our example messages merely represent
events happening in the real world like
order received package shipped etc let's
see cat outs flow of events with cloud
pub/sub now the order service instead of
sending messages directly to the
packaging service will just send these
messages to pub/sub where they will be
stored the packaging service and the
notification service will receive these
messages either by a push or a pull
packaging service instead of directly
sending messages to shipping service
would send them to pub cell and the
event will be received by the shipping
and notification service the packaging
service did not need to know which
services are receiving this event this
makes it simple
similarly the shipping service sends the
messages to pub/sub from where the order
and the
notification service pull or receive
those messages by using cloud pub/sub
we've solved a lot of problems that we
had in the earlier architecture but one
we've made each piece simpler since it
only needs to emit an event without
worrying about who gets it or receive an
event without much care about how it got
there but more importantly this is more
scalable it reduces dependencies
services can change and don't need to
know about each other's changes all that
need to be made sure is that they are
subscribing to pub/sub and receiving the
right messages it's also much easier now
to introduce new services if our new
monitoring service pops up all we need
to do is make sure it subscribes to the
messages from the existing service we
are cloud pub/sub the architecture with
cloud pub/sub has built in resilience if
any service were to break down pops up
will store the messages for seven days
or until the service comes back up and
it's delivered them and because pops up
is fully managed service you don't have
to worry about it being single point of
failure it's scalable and resilient and
can handle millions of messages
simultaneously all right so today we
learned when to use cloud pub/sub and
the common challenges it solves join us
next time to learn how it works and some
of the most common use cases you like
this video and would like to see more
such content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel